I have to ask you about your new
accessory can I see this how stunning is
that thank you
this is this did he know what you wanted
or did did he surprise you he surprised
me but I do want to get the man of the
hour in here hi Ryan are you talking
about getting this ring from Aaron I
kind of know what she likes and I had
somebody in Canada to kind of put it
together like the stone is from New York
City it's like an uncut diamond and then
the rest of its just like cast just
custom for her because I didn't I don't
know I couldn't like just buy something
to make it something and how did you
react when you saw oh I saw I mean it
was so emotional and so perfect it was
earlier in July we got engaged and he
just he's a very thoughtful human being
and I feel like the proposal was just as
thoughtful as he always says so it was
perfect
how was wedding planning going are you
thinking about that part of it yet here
and there yeah we are um I think we're
kind of honing in on like the spring
time before we like kick off our tours
again but yeah we're going very slow at
a glacial pace I think we're just
enjoying being engaged meirin also
opened up about new music confirming
she's in the songwriting process and
wouldn't mind teaming up with another
soulful singer Kesha to just be a woman
in the industry and be that blunt and
upfront about what you're going through
is really really incredible to me and it
makes me want to strive to be more
honest in my songs et spoke with the 27
year old country star at the 11th annual
ACM honors where she's performing a
tribute to the late Glenn Campbell he
was lost too soon and from one of the
most like devastating diseases that I've
had family members passed away from I
feel very fortunate to be able to honor
him in this way
[Music]